how's it going going good it's decent
so I grew up in Russia I lived there
from ages 3 to 15 ever since we moved to
the u.s. I've always been confused by
this question how's it going like no one
ever answers the question all right I'm
gonna prove it to you how's it going
how's it going not even a little detail
how's it going how's it going
again nothing how's it going I got this
what does that mean how's it going
he answered my how's it going with the
housing going
[Music]
so now that I've proved to you that
nobody ever answers the question how is
it going I'm gonna actually take some
time to sit down next to someone and see
if we can have a genuine conversation
how's it going man yeah dude busy yeah
it's been crimey n-- it's been crazy
how's it going good cool nice to meet
you how's it going how's your day good
yeah I give up that was the most awkward
thing I've ever experienced I thought it
was gonna be like a video where I like
met all these people
no it's extremely uncomfortable it's
awkward no one wants to talk about their
day or like open up their feelings so
instead of putting myself through more
awkward interactions I'm gonna go around
with a microphone I'm gonna see why
people think no one answers the question
how's it going
Sarah do you have time for an interview
I it's too late we're gonna do it it's a
one-question interview how's it going
all right how's it going with you it's
good good
so how many times have you heard how is
it going in the past week every day how
many times have you answered it other
than saying it's fine never why do you
think no one ever answers the question
how's it going you don't want to get too
personal I guess I think it's because
usually they answers to depressing I
mean go to a therapist nobody's ever
gonna say it's going bad I once tried to
changing how are you - are you good and
everyone was like do I look okay is
there something wrong I hate when people
like if people were to really ask me
that because it would like uncork some
deep [ __ ]
I never asked oh you never ask like the
head nut and if you give it back then I
know you did I honestly think the world
would be better if we just didn't talk
to people at all what I'm realizing is
that everyone at BuzzFeed hates
interaction and is bitter and I'm the
only one who cares about connecting with
other human beings
I guess I could get rid of how's it
going completely my problem with how's
it going is when people ask and
immediately stop listening so how was
your day it's good so I'm currently
editing this video and I just washed
back all the footage even though this
video is silly and funny and it's not
supposed to be serious I feel like
there's actually a pretty important
lesson to be learned from this video and
I think there's something so important
about listening and talking to the
people around you cuz you never know who
needs to be talked to her who wants to
be heard or who has some problems that
they need to share so it's really
important to listen and you should take
the time to sit down and talk to the
people you care about and really ask
people how is it going so if you guys
feel like it in the comments below just
tell me how it's going
[Music]